[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i got questions and i hope
tom silverstein has answers packers beat
reporter for the milwaukee journal
sentinel if i asked you a week ago what
you thought was going to happen
how different would that be with the
scenario we have this week tom
a week ago i would have predicted what
happened
a month ago i would not have predicted
that
uh when i started to see reports that
this wasn't about
money you know this was about principal
and things like that that's when i knew
he was going to report because
it was sort of uh the process of him
saving face getting back you know
deciding that
okay it's time to play football and time
to end this
whole thing so that's kind of the
feeling i got a week ago
what's going to happen today so he'll
come in all right apparently he is in i
i didn't track his plane
i am kind of behind them
you're slipping you're slipping if this
was fine no i know
you would have i did have all my bellmen
at the airport
[Laughter]
and uh so he'll report with the rest of
the veterans
they do some conditioning i i think what
will really happen is he'll go right
to the front office and sit down and
they'll talk about
exactly what's going to happen with his
contract
with his demands you know what they're
gonna
actually do for him and then i assume
he's gonna report
and they'll practice tomorrow morning
okay
i got a couple of questions here that
and help me understand the language are
they going to sign an addendum here
and then how does it work that aaron
rodgers
if he wants doesn't want to stay then he
can
he's still going to be traded but he can
tell the packers where he wants to be
traded
yeah so we're all dealing on the basis
of the reports which we know are coming
from his agent
and so there's a
let me start there's a couple of things
i'm still really skeptical about
one is that there's no new money in the
deal
if that's true then
i wonder why he went through all of this
in the first place
because i mean let's let's be honest
about
pro professional sports and and
players versus teams it's about money
and and money can
it may not he may not need the money but
it's a pride factor
and so i i'm guessing
what they're doing is they're removing
the final year of the contract
which effectively makes it necessary for
the packers to trade him next off season
if he wants to be traded it'll be no
problem because
they're not going to let him get to that
year of free agency
because if he go leaves in free agency
they get nothing for him basically a cop
so they're going to want to trade them
next off season jordan love will have
had
two years in the system uh they
you know the best case scenarios they
win a super bowl this year
rogers moves on and and goes and tries
to win a super bowl next year now
there is supposedly language that he can
be deny
trades you know he can pick the team
that he wants to go to
so there will have to be some kind of
sign and trade but
to me all of it and i hate to say it
pains me to say it but i
i think the packers it's not the
narrative but i think the packers came
out on top on this
i really do i mean you can't go against
the nfl
a single guy cannot go against the nfl
and win they're a
mega corporation and they got rules in
place that
kill you as an employee and i think i
think
he didn't get that much if i could
take the packers back to february and
you could trade rogers
or go back to draft night when they took
jordan love
right which do-over would the packers
take
i i think if they knew he wasn't going
to play
i mean i guess this is probably me the
the fantasy
uh general manager talking but i would
have traded him
in february but it's
it's regardless trading them now
they could do it but as it's been
pointing it out to me numerous times if
they trade them next
spring they know what kind of picks
they're getting yeah you know they know
if they're trading them if if it's
denver and denver's coming off a 6-10
season that's a great thing for them
right
if they trade them now and and they
trade them to
denver and denver goes 12-4 then those
picks are not worth all that much
so at least they would know what they're
getting and they could
set the compensation that way and i
wondered
if if you knew that you were probably
headed towards some kind of divorce
you could have traded him like the night
of the draft i know adam schefter made
it
sound like it was imminent you could
have traded him to san francisco had the
three pick overall
and whatever else in there or the rams
you could go back and
the rams probably would have signed up
for aaron rodgers before matthew
stafford i i think there were so many
options out there tom
that's why even now if aaron rodgers
goes hey i want to go to denver
well what's denver give up that's true
compensation for aaron rodgers
but hey you promised him that you're
going to trade i mean it's just
the gray area here is you know
yeah dark shade of gray yeah and i think
you
you mentioned it what if he gets hurt
this year and then
you know he plays six games and he's
coming off as some kind of an injury
then what are you going to get for him
and who's going to want to trade for him
at 39 years old or 38 years old and and
injured now that that's a risk every
player goes through but
to me the packers felt that this was
somewhat of a bluff and they were right
you know in the end they were right
it was a bluff he's back they're gonna
make
this has been a three-year process to
get to the super bowl you know they've
been to two nfc championships
they've built the team they filled a
bunch of holes uh
this year and
now you know they have their quarterback
in place and whatever happens after this
year they're in
they're in salary cap hell anyways so
that's kind of an all or win
all or nothing year for them so they
needed rogers they really didn't need
roger
okay so if you're devante adams rogers
is back
he's probably saying hey if i'm coming
back i want devonta adams signed up
long term if you're devante adams do you
sign up for a long-term contract
or do you say i want the same deal as
aaron rodgers
if if if i'm devante adams and they
throw down
40 million guarantee or 40 million
signing bonus or whatever
you're gonna take it you you you take
what you know
you know with with the organization that
you like where you
felt you've been treated okay i i think
the whole devante adams thing was a
negotiating ploy
and it's been used for years and years
and
i remember when brett favre was going
through
this ryan grant was a running back with
packers whose contract was up
or wanted a renegotiation and he used it
perfectly you know and got a great deal
out of it he didn't want to leave
i mean i don't think devante adams wants
to leave okay
but why not use whatever you can to
leverage you know as leverage so you can
get a lot of money i
i think they'll get a deal done with
with adams i don't think that's going to
be a problem
and and i think ultimately he'll either
play
enjoy playing with jordan love or
somebody else don't if jordan love
doesn't pan out then they'll go after
somebody else
do you know if they have a true
assessment of jordan love right now tom
that no i don't think so i think they
have
all of the athletic assessment but
they have no idea how he's going to
react during
um actual play they this is
this is kind of going to be the summer
of jordan love i think
you know rogers will get a lot of the
practice snaps but we'll call it
the summer of love is what we need to
call it time yes summer in love yeah
i just saw that movie that's really good
too i
i think i think he will play almost all
the snaps
you know blake bortles will get a
handful of snaps but george this is
this is the summer for jordan love to
get as many snaps as possible
and for them to to really get him to
advance you get one question
for rogers what do you ask him
what did you get out of it i i think
that's really it what did you get
out of five months of
uh you know drama was it was it worth it
did causing angst amongst packers fans
and
and the organization and all of that was
that
revenge for you did you feel that that
even the scales uh for whatever
grievances you have against the packers
i guess that would be my question and i
and i felt like it was a little bit of a
pr move
with his agent or agents by telling
shefty
hey we told you this wasn't about money
right yeah exactly yeah
well yeah i mean i tweeted that like it
just seems like
all of a sudden now uh negotiations are
on with devante adams
i you know i sort of felt like they were
gonna say okay
uh you know the negotiations are on with
devonte
adams he didn't get any new money and
the wildfires out west have gone out
you know all because aaron rodgers is
coming back
you know i i expected that to be in
there too
uh this just in from tom pelicero aaron
rodgers has arrived
at lambeau field just want to let you
know
tom i gotta go yeah i'll let you go uh
tom thank you as always
i appreciate your time uh it was a
pleasure any time tom silverstein the
packers beat reporter milwaukee journal
sentinel